alexander gauland jetzt das erste mal
die afg also als stärkste
oppositionsfraktion darf jetzt hier
antworten der parteien 20 zulegen und
kollegen in den deutschen kinos läuft
zurzeit der film die dunkelste stunde
über den englischen kriegspremier
winston churchill
es ist ein lehrfilm über die kraft des
wortes in einer fast ausweglosen
situation als england sich mit fast
leeren händen und eben
leidenschaftlichen worten verteidigen
musste nun liegt es mir fern die frau
bundeskanzlerin mit dem wortgewaltigen
winston churchill vergleichen zu wollen
aber ein bisschen mehr pathos ein
bisschen mehr tiefgang oder auch das was
helmut schmidt mal kritisch vision
genannt hat das würde ich und hätte ich
mir schon gewünscht die wellen kann
denn sie behaupten ja wieder eine
gespaltene gesellschaft versöhnen zu
wollen
auch mit der kraft der ansprache die
nicht mehr ganz so große koalition
sozusagen als schmiermittel zur
integration der täglich neu ankommenden
in die gemeinschaft der schon länger
hier leben wird von deutschen frau
bundeskanzlerin war bei ihnen schon
lange nicht mehr die rede und im
geschriebenen text habe ich nicht
gefunden aber sie haben das erste mal
wieder von deutschen gesprochen
das ist der erfolg der afd
ja ich weiß einmal in der
legislaturperiode schwören sie einen eid
und der gemahnt sie an die verpflichtung
schaden vom deutschen volk fernzuhalten
dass sie das aus unserer sicht ich tun
belegen die koalitionsverhandlungen
die masseneinwanderung frau
bundeskanzlerin geht ungebremst weiter
eine obergrenze gefordert einmal von
ihrem innenminister gibt es nicht
und allein der zufall und die
wetterkonditionen auf dem mittelmeer
entscheiden über die zahl der
neuankömmlinge herrschaft des unrechts
hat ihr innenminister das einmal genannt
und wird darin von einem deutschen
obergericht im oberlandesgericht koblenz
bestätigt dass in seiner
urteilsbegründung von 14 2 2017 die
bemerkenswerten sätze schrieb ich
zitiere mit erlaubnis des präsidenten
20 der betroffene durch seine unerlaubte
einreise in die bundesrepublik strafbar
gemacht die rechtsstaatliche ordnung in
der bundesrepublik ist in diesem bereich
jedoch seit rund eineinhalb jahren außer
kraft gesetzt und die illegale einreise
in die bundesrepublik wird momentan de
facto nicht mehr strafrechtlich
verfolgen zitat ende
meine damen und herren vor
bundeskanzlerin rechtsbruch als
dauerzustand und kein ende abzusehen
und wenn ich mir ihren koalitionsvertrag
anschaue und die leidenschaft mir vor
augen führen mit ihnen
erstaunlicherweise besonders
sozialdemokraten den familiennachzug
subsidiär geschützter also von menschen
die kein dauerhaftes aufenthaltsrecht
jahren durchgesetzt haben
1000 pro monat und härtefälle obenauf
frage ich mich welche verkäuferin in
dresden oder welcher bandarbeiter in
wolfsburg daran auch nur das geringste
interesse aber sie müssen ja wissen für
wen sie politik machen
weder im wahlkampf noch im
koalitionsvertrag noch in der
regierungserklärung spielen attentäter
messer morde und vergewaltigungen eine
rolle auch nicht die tatsache dass die
kriminalitätsrate unter migranten
erheblich höher ist als unter
einheimischen auch nicht die
aberwitzigen kosten die kommen gar nicht
vor der illegalen zuwanderung in höhe
von 50 milliarden jährlich die das
institut der deutschen wirtschaft
berechnet hat in dem land in dem sie gut
und gerne leben frau bundeskanzlerin
bekommt ein syrer mit zwei ehefrauen und
sechs kindern in pinneberg ein ganzes
haus und übrige sozialleistungen
geschenkt während immer mehr deutsche
obdachlos werden
allein hier in berlin gibt es 6000 davon
und immer mehr rentner verarmt sind und
an lebensmittel tafeln essen müssen
und wenn das dann nicht zusammengeht
müssen sich die freiwilligen helfer der
tafeln auch noch beschimpfen lassen wie
kürzlich in essen
ja frau bundeskanzlerin die gesellschaft
zerfällt
sie selbst haben im fernsehen vor no go
areas gewalt sie haben gesagt ich
zitiere sie solche räume gibt es und das
muss man auch beim namen nennen und man
muss etwas dagegen tun
wer bitteschön ist man frau
bundeskanzlerin
die folgen ihrer politik der offenen
grenzen holen sie aber nicht nur in der
innenpolitik an den niemand in europa
wie die folgen dieser politik tragen zu
recht sagen die polen ungarn slowaken
tschechen wenn frau merkel menschen nach
deutschland holt geht uns das nichts an
wir haben die einladungen nicht
ausgesprochen und recht haben diese
völker und ihren staatsmänner das
selbstbestimmungsrecht eines volkes
umfasst natürlich auch das recht zu
bestimmen mit wem ich zusammenleben will
und wen ich in meine gemeinschaft
aufnehmen
es gibt keine pflicht zu vielfalt und
buntheit es gibt auch keine pflicht
meinen starts raum mit fremden menschen
zu teilen indem sie immer von neuen den
versuch machen frau bundeskanzlerin die
fehler ihrer politik anderen aufzubürden
spalten sie europa herrn tus kamen sie
auf diesem wege schon verloren
andere werden folgen das ruiniert aber
schon im ansatz ihren anspruch die
europäer zusammenzuführen und da nichts
umsonst ist in der welt staatlicher
interessen müssten sie jetzt herr marco
weit entgegenkommen mit allen möglichen
finanzpolitischen unverdaulich keiten
die am ende auf eine transfer-union mit
neuen deutschen lasten hinauslaufen
sie haben sich frau bundeskanzlerin in
europa mit ihrer flüchtlingspolitik
soweit isoliert dass sie dankbar sein
müssen wenn der französische präsident
ihrer finanziellen opfer huldvoll
entgegennimmt deutschen interessen meine
damen und herren die das schon lange
nicht mehr
aber wir folgen ja auch nicht deutschem
interesse sondern einem imaginären
europäischen wie immer das auch
definiert und so kümmern die
bundeskanzlerin und ihren neuen
außenminister nur an eine warnung ja
lachen sie jetzt gleich otto von
bismarcks erinnern der einmal
feststellte ich habe das wort europa
immer im munde derjenigen politiker
gefunden die von anderen mächten etwas
verlangten dass sie im eigenen namen
nicht zu fordern sagte vielleicht fragen
sie mal ihren kollegen den präsidenten
vom markt
nach diesem zitat meine damen und herren
auch wenn sie das anders sehen es hat
sich in der außenpolitik eben nicht so
viel geändert seit den tagen bis marx
und deswegen kann man das wohl sehr gut
daran ein danke
ja so weit also alexander gauland hat
die festhalten dass das wetter
inzwischen die stimme darüber wie hoch
die zahl der flüchtlinge in deutschland
seien der rechtsbruch als dauerzustand
und es sei kein in der achse war klagte
er 50 milliarden jährlich kosten
die wanderung die gesellschaft zu fall
sogar landwirtin und winterfest und
walfang granate vor dass ihre politik am
ende in europa zu einer transferunion
führen würde unsicher das ist kein
gefühl das ist so und das hat konkrete
auswirkungen für unser leben und wir
haben diese bundesregierung und die ich
mir für die diese regierung tragenden
fraktionen gebildet um die konflikte die
es gibt nicht noch weiter anzuheizen
sondern um diese konflikte zu lösen
brücken zu bauen und auch deutsche
interessen auf dieser basis zu vertreten
und wenn wir darüber reden was diese
welt unsicher macht dann muss man
darüber reden was wir an militärischen
konflikten derzeit haben zum beispiel in
syrien mit weitreichenden konsequenzen
auch für unser land aber wir sind auch
besorgt über das verhalten unseres
bündnispartners türkei für staaten gilt
das gewaltverbot in den internationalen
beziehungen nur in ausnahmesituationen
kann diese regel etwa durch das recht
zur selbstverteidigung kurzfristig
ausgesetzt werden es gibt berechtigte
zweifel dass ein angriff durch die
syrischen kurden auf die türkei erfolgt
ist oder eine direkte bedrohung
türkischen staatsgebietes vorliegt weder
die verhältnismäßigkeit noch die dauer
des einsatzes der des türkischen
militärs dürfen zur begründung der
selbstverteidigung ausreichen dieses
völkerrechtswidrige verhalten halten wir
deswegen nicht für akzeptabel
auch die bewaffneten konflikte in
afghanistan im irak und in der ukraine
sowie die unsichere lage auf der
koreanischen halbinsel erfüllen uns mit
sorge und erfordern umsichtiges vorgehen
aber auch eine klare haltung und ich
sage hier wir haben einen
funktionierenden kompass das kann man
leider nicht von allen fraktionen in
diesem haus sagen bestimmt nicht von der
afg die sich vom syrischen diktator
assad für seine propaganda zwecke hat
einfallen lassen
zur frage stationiert wenn ich aber sage
wir haben eine unsichere dann sind das
durchaus auch wirtschaftliche konflikte
die sorgen machen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
strafzölle sind nunmal relikte aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert es sind keine
passenden antworten für die probleme des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts unser
standpunkt ist klar wir brauchen freien
und fairen handel ist gut für alle alles
andere schadet übrigens auch den usa
davon bin ich fest überzeugt
ich bin finanzminister olaf scholz und
wirtschaftsminister hat man dankbar dass
sie den direkten austausch gesucht haben
aber wenn es nun zu diesen straftaten
kommt dann bin ich der meinung müssen
wir genauso entschlossen auch darauf
reagieren
genauso entschlossen sollten wir aber
auch uns überlegen was für konflikte
wirtschaftlicher art sind noch da wir
haben einen chinesischen
staatskapitalismus der von betrieblicher
mitbestimmung weit entfernt ist und der
mit sicherheit hier auch große
herausforderung darstellt und auf der
anderen seite monopole
silicon valley lässt grüßen die zwar mit
einer menschenrechts rhetorische
herkommen aber nicht bereit sind hier
steuern zu zahlen und arbeitnehmerrechte
zu wand und deswegen sage ich muss es
antworten geben und die eine antwort die
wir alle hier haben ist ein starkes
europa denn das ist tatsächlich einer
der wesentlichen punkte um die es gehen
muss dieses europa zu stärken und die
zusammenarbeit in europa zu verbessern
und deswegen ist es ein gutes zeichen
dass sowohl sie frau bundeskanzlerin als
auch olaf scholz der vizekanzler und
finanzminister ikom maß der
bundesaußenminister sofort nach
amtsantritt nach paris geflogen sind und
dort eben die kontakte und die
gesprächsfäden aufgegriffen haben
denn nur die achse deutschland
frankreich kann diesen zusammenhalt in
europa wirklich vorantreiben
es gibt texte in europa sie investieren
viel zeit und geld um europa zu
destabilisieren
wir die bundesrepublik deutschland
müssen daher zeit und geld investieren
um europa zusammenzuhalten
das ist unsere verpflichtung und unser
auftrag damit das gelingt muss die
europäische union gestärkt und
reformiert werden das ist keine frage
wir brauchen eine vertiefung der
wirtschafts und währungsunion die frau
bundeskanzlerin ich das eben sehr
präzise beschrieben
um diese krisenfester und auch
wachstumsfreundliche zu machen wir
brauchen den aufbau aber auch eine
gemeinsame außen und sicherheitspolitik
das ist gerade für die osteuropäer eine
ganz entscheidende frage und wir
brauchen einen weiteren an gleich der
lebensverhältnisse
der nächste haushalt der europäischen
union muss ein investitionshaushalt sein
und wir brauchen mindeststandards
sozialer natur
damit dieses europa auch zusammenhält
und das ist ein entscheidender punkt den
wir auch im koalitionsvertrag
niedergelegt habe wenn ich sage dir
brauchen als eine antwort auf die
unsicherheit ein starkes europa dann ist
die andere antwort und selbst zu stärken
auch im inneren stärke entsteht nach
meiner einschätzung durch zusammenhalt
den zusammenhalt in unserem land zu
festigen und gute perspektiven für die
zukunft aller in unserem land zu
eröffnen
das ist das große ziel dieser
bundesregierung auch hier gilt wir
wollen die konflikte die es in unserer
gesellschaft gibt nicht noch anheizen
sondern sie lösen und wir fangen damit
an dass über den alltagssorgen
alltagssorgen der menschen eben auch
beginnen
nehmen wir zum beispiel eines der themen
das mir zunehmend begegnet zusammenhalt
das ist zum beispiel gute nachbarschaft
ein zuhause in dem man sich aufgehoben
fühlt die nachbarschaft in der man sich
kennt und hilft der kiez in dem die
kinder zur schule gehen dass es eben
auch heimat im besten sinne
doch in den ballungszentren ist zum
beispiel diese ganz simple sache heimat
unter druck in münchen schwabing in der
ankerstraße zum beispiel haben
mieterinnen und mieter das ganz konkret
erlebt es beginnt damit dass ein
schreiben ins haus flattert
modernisierungs maßnahmen werden
angekündigt zentralheizung einbauen neue
elektroleitungen fenster austauschen
aufzug kellerdecke dach dem balkon
vergrößern
die miete
und das gleich mit angekündigt dafür 450
die miete von heute auf morgen schon mal
von 560 euro auf 2100 euro das mag ein
extremes beispiel sein aber es ist real
passiert und es ist nicht der einzige
ort in deutschland wo es passiert ich
glaube dass die frage bezahlbaren
wohnens eine der zentralen sozialen
fragen des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts geworden ist auch in berlin
in frankfurt in düsseldorf oder münchen
bürgerinnen und bürgern werden mit
luxussanierungen und explodierenden
mieten aus ihrer heimat aus ihrem
angestammten fort ihr getränk das ist
absolut nicht akzeptabel und deswegen
wollen wir dagegen vorgehen wir wollen
extreme mieterhöhungen nach
modernisierung oder sanierung stoppen
wir wollen mehr und vor allem
bezahlbaren wohnraum schaffen und auch
jungen familien mit dem baukindergeld
unterstützung beim kauf eines eigentums
zukommen lassen das ist das paket und
darüber werden wir hoffentlich sehr
schnell schon gesetzesinitiativen hier
in diesem haus beratung zusammenhalt
brauchen wir menschen aufeinander
angewiesen sind
das ist für mich auch der bereich pflege
viele pflegerinnen und pfleger in
unserem land können davon berichten was
es heißt in der nachtschicht allein
verantwortlich zu sein für 50
patientinnen und patienten teilweise
schwer krank von der angst davor dass
was passiert von der erleichterung wenn
die schicht ohne katastrophe überstanden
ist ja die aufgaben im bereich
gesundheit und pflege
die vor uns liegen sind groß und sie
erfordern die volle konzentration des
zuständigen ministers liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das ministerium könnte
die arbeit aufnehmen denn wir haben den
koalitionsvertrag zahlreiche und
konkrete maßnahmen vereinbart und die
situation der pflegenden und jetzt
pflegekräfte auch zu verbessern mehr
geld für pflegepersonal und eine
personal mindestgrenze das ist nämlich
sehr wichtig zu betonen neben den 8000
neuen fachkraft stellen die frau merkel
oder bessere löhne über einen
tarifvertrag soziales und
unbürokratische hilfe für pflegende
angehörige
schon bald werden uns also sicher hier
auch erste gesetzesinitiativen erreichen
zusammenhalt das bedeutet aus meiner
sicht aber auch dass wir das ziel der
vollbeschäftigung erreichen wollen
das können wir das werden wir
hoffentlich ich bin sehr optimistisch
aber das gelingt nicht wenn wir nicht
auch den endlich eine perspektive geben
die schon seit vielen jahren
langzeitarbeitslos sind und hier ist
entscheidende punkt dass wir den leuten
nicht maßnahmen anbieten
das haben wir oft genug sechs wochen
sechs monate wer das ein paar mal
mitgemacht ein empfindet es als
demütigend was wir machen wollen ist
denen über den sozialen arbeitsmarkt ich
bin sicher dass sowie haiders sehr
schnell auch anpacken wird dass wir das
anpacken und den menschen arbeit geben
arbeitsverträge arbeit ist wurde und das
ist es worum es hierbei geht und darüber
bin ich sehr glücklich dass wir das
gemeinsam verabredete wir werden überall
in
allen jobcentern in deutschland dieses
anbieten können und das absichern können
und haben das auch finanziert
zusammenhalt ist aber auch ein
funktionierender generationenvertrag
wir spielen nicht jung und alt
gegeneinander aus sondern schaffen für
jung und alt als planungssicherheit denn
die stabilisierung des rentenniveaus ist
vor allem für die jüngeren eine gute
nachricht die sich nämlich darauf
verlassen können müssen ja der car
classics mehr muss man das so auch die
gesetzliche säule in zukunft die
zentrale säule des deutschen
rentensystems bleibt auf die alle auf
die jüngeren ran kommt das ist der
entscheidende vorteil
und ich denke dass insbesondere im
bereich der rente die verhinderung von
altersarmut durch die grundrente
wirklich für langjährig versicherte ein
wesentlicher baustein sein wird ich
denke wenn wir über zusammenhalt regel
reden heißt das aber aus meiner sicht
auch in die integration der neu zu uns
kommen den menschen wirklich zu
investieren
jede investition in sprache in die
integration in den arbeitsmarkt und die
bundesagentur für arbeit ist nicht auf
akkus über 250.000 menschen sind bereits
in den ersten arbeitsmarkt integriert
worden
das ist doch eine sehr positive
entwicklung die wir weiter verstärken
müssen
ich glaube dass an dieser stelle jeder
euro den wir da investieren einen euro
in die unsere eigene zukunft ist gerade
vor dem hintergrund der demografischen
situation unseres landes und was wir
wirklich dringend brauchen ist ein
einwanderungsgesetz denn wir wollen ein
geordnetes verfahren wir wollen steuern
aber wir wollen auch weltoffenheit und
wir brauchen vor allem die menschen die
zu uns kommen und deswegen ist es ja nun
nach vielen vielen jahren der diskussion
auch ein gemeinsames projekt geworden
wofür ich mich ausdrücklich bedanken
möchte es dürfte
in diesem haus grund strittig sein dass
der bildungspolitik für die zukunft
unseres landes eine enorme bedeutung
zukommt von der verbesserung unserer
bildungslandschaft und zwar von der
frühkindlichen bildung bis hin zur
weiterbildung hängt es ab ob wir in zehn
jahren ein starkes land mit sicheren
arbeitsplätzen sind davon bin ich fest
überzeugt
die ersten weichen werden in der bildung
früh gestellt franziska gefahr wird sich
darum bemühen die frühkindliche bildung
auch qualitativ weiter voranzubringen
insgesamt investieren wir in dieser
legislaturperiode 11 milliarden
zusätzlich in bildung in kitas in
digitale ausstattung in ganztagsschulen
in berufsschulen in studienplätze in
bafög in meister bafög und in
weiterbildung mit einer nationalen
weiterbildungs strategie und einem recht
auf weiterbildungsberatung und ich sage
an dieser stelle
wer die digitalisierung anpackt der muss
das zusammen auch mit den
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
machen das ist keine rein technische
sache wir brauchen auch hier die
gewerkschaften denn nur so können wir
die stärke die unser land hat aus meiner
sicht auch für die zukunft ausschließen
und deswegen ist diese weiterbildungs
strategie auf eine die wir zusammen
insbesondere mitteln arbeitnehmerin den
arbeitgeber machen müssen in der
koalition sind jetzt einig wir wollen
das grundgesetz ändern
um die kommunen zu unterstützen bildung
auch dann so zu organisieren dass das
geld auch in den schulen vor ort ankommt
wir wollen dass diese mittel direkt
ankommen
das ist eine große herausforderung und
ich hoffe dass wir in diesem haus für
dieses vorhaben auch von anderen
fraktionen unterstützung bekommen denn
das ist notwendig und es ist ein
wichtiges anliegen für unser land
wir müssen den strukturwandel und
wirtschaft vorantreiben und gerade bei
der digitalisierung haben wir jetzt
genug angekündigt
ich denke jetzt geht es darum es
umzusetzen ich glaube da ist uns allen
klar
und diese dynamik die brauchen wir auch
an dieser stelle denn es ist tatsächlich
wichtig wir haben gar keinen so
schlechten platz wenn er sich die
roboter sierung 1 kug sind wir platz
fünf in der welt aber das ist eben ein
auftrag an uns alle dass uns es uns
gelingt diese potenziale so oft schießen
dass wir da auch welt niveau erreichen
wo wir es noch nicht haben und halten wo
wir es haben nichts weniger dürfen wir
uns vornehmen in diesem sektor dann bin
ich mir ganz sicher für die nächsten
jahre dynamik brauchen wir auch beim
klimaschutz
ich will das ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin
sehr glücklich dass wir ein
klimaschutzgesetz machen werden im jahre
2019 denn es geht darum dass wir auch
ganz konkrete maßnahmen verabreden wie
wir die klimaziele auch erreichen wollen
und ich glaube an dieser stelle ist es
gleichzeitig wisst ich noch in diesem
jahr wird er die kommission wachstum
strukturwandel und beschäftigung ihre
arbeit aufnehmen und bis jahresende ein
plan für die struktur entwicklung in den
braunkohle gebieten vorlegen aber auch
ein end ausstiegsdatum aus der
braunkohle soll vereinbart werden
und das ist für mich der
interessenausgleich für den wir hier
stehen müssen
wir müssen klimaschutz einerseits
vorantreiben auf der anderen seite die
betroffenen regionen mitnehmen und
weiter entwickeln und deswegen ist das
für mich eine gleichrangige aufgabe und
es ist keine kleine aufgabe aber ich bin
mir sicher dass peter altmaier und auch
svenja schulze das sehr gut machen sind
sie kommen beide aus einer region wo
struktur entwicklung offen gesprochen
schon fast zu dna der jeweiligen
bundesländer gehören und deswegen ist
das da sicher in guten händen
sonst wären wir da noch einmal genauer
hingucken müssen an dieser stelle
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
möchte sehr klar sagen dass wir auch
wenn wir über die zukunft die dynamik
den aufruf für unser land reden neue
mobilitätskonzepte brauchen und ich sage
an dieser stelle ganz klar dass ich noch
nicht im detail weiß wie wir die
quadratur des kreises hin fliegen wollen
aber ich bin sicher dass wir an dieser
stelle eine gemeinsamkeit haben wir
können die betroffenen kommunen damit
nicht alleine hängen lassen und wir
können auch und das müssen wir klar
sagen die betroffenen diesel fahrerinnen
und diesel fahrer nicht hängen lassen
hier gibt es die verantwortung der
automobilindustrie
für mich ist auch klar fahrverbote
müssen so gut es geht vermieden werden
sie müssen absolut die ausnahme bleiben
und deswegen sind alle anderen maßnahmen
an dieser stelle auf prioritär für diese
skandale aber auch die jüngsten daten
liegt bei facebook zeigen dass wir die
rechte der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher
ich habe ich in dieser legislaturperiode
noch mal neu gewichten müssen sie haben
eine viel größere bedeutung als in der
vergangenheit
hier wird viel stärker erfasst die
möglichkeiten für die konsumentinnen und
konsumenten sind riesig aber auch die
manipulation enorm
und deswegen ist es sehr wichtig dass
katarina barley als neue
bundesjustizministerin direkt die
initiative für eine muster
feststellungsklage auf den weg gebracht
hat denn das gehört für mich zu einer
modernen digitalen wirtschaft eben auch
dazu dass sie an dieser stelle klar auch
die rechte der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher stärken und schützen
die kolleginnen und kollegen für eine
lebendige demokratie ist auch die
lebendige parlamentarische arbeit das
geht uns hier alle an zentral
dazu werden wir das parlament auch
stärken beispielsweise indem wir
regelmäßige orientierungs debatten
führen in denen es jenseits des
täglichen geschäfts und grundsätzliche
fragen geht wir wollen auf eine
regelmäßige befragung der
bundeskanzlerin im plenum durch die
abgeordneten einführen
ob das gelingt liegt aber nicht an der
regierung und der die regierung
tragenden fraktionen alleine und
deswegen laden wir alle hier dazu ein
sich daran zu beteiligen
ja denn ich denke wir sind uns einig
dass der deutsche bundestag der zentrale
ort der debatte sein soll
die ministerinnen und minister können
sich bei der umsetzung der vielen guten
projekte des koalitionsvertrages auf die
spd fraktion verlassen
das will ich klar sagen wir werden das
eng begleiten füge ich hinzu
im parlament als zentraler auch der
politischen debatte werden wir die
interessen und stimmen aber auch der
bürgerinnen und bürger aus unseren
wahlkreisen verbänden und
interessenvertretungen aufnehmen sie
einbringen in die beratung der
gesetzentwürfe und das führt dann eben
auch manchmal dazu dass diese
gesetzentwürfe noch mal geändert werden
das ist die arbeit dieses parlamentes
die wir leisten müssen und das ist auch
unser mandat und für mich heißt diese
arbeit jeden tag zu beweisen dass die
parlamentarische demokratie die beste
aller staatsformen ist und das müssen
wir uns jeden tag klar machen diesen
beweis jeden tag neu anzutreten das ist
das gemeinsame ziel dieses parlament ist
vielen dank während die bundeskommission
herz auf die ernte war dieser rede gab
es applaus von martin schulze unter den
abgeordneter spd sitzt er hat er
gemeinsam mit andrea nahles hauptamtlich
hier dieses produktionsergebnis
erarbeitet und andrea nahles hat hier
noch einmal dargestellt zusammenhalt
vereinigen auch in deutschland um ihn zu
festigen das sei das hauptziel der
bundesregierung andrea nahles fing ihre
rede mit einem aus politischen parteien
verurteilt das völkerrechtswidrige
verhalten der türkei sei so nicht
akzeptabel sagte sie und sie spaß ich
auch für freie und faire handel
ausgesetzt auf die usa jetzt nicht der
redner christian lindner der partei- und
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen helmut
kohl regierte 16 jahre
er war ein großer kanzler der sich um
europa und deutschland historische
verdienste erworben hat
am ende dieser wahlperiode frau
bundeskanzlerin werden auch sie 16 jahre
regiert haben aber der charakter ihrer
kanzlerschaft ist offen
und sie selbst sind dafür die beste
zeugen
ich kann mich nicht erinnern jemals eine
regierungschefin gehört zu haben
wie so oft gesagt hat seien wir ehrlich
sagen wir die wahrheit das wirft die
frage nach den vergangenen zwölf jahren
auf
der charakter der kanzlerschaft ist
offen werden sie europa in der
sicherheits- und migrationspolitik
handlungsfähig machen oder neue
fliehkräfte durch falsche
weichenstellungen in der währungsunion
entfachen können sie den durch ihre
flüchtlingspolitik entstandenen
vertrauensverlust durch eine vernünftige
einwanderungs und integrationspolitik
überwinden werden sie die
wirtschaftliche stärke dieses landes nur
verbraucht haben oder die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit sicher werden sie
unsere gesellschaft für die zukunft
gestärkt haben oder den sozialstaat mit
einer hypothek übergeben werden wir nach
ihrer amtszeit das digitale neuland
betreten haben oder hinnehmen müssen
dass südkorea und viele andere
gesellschaften uns abgegangen haben
diese fragen entscheiden über den
charakter ihrer kanzlerschaft nach ihrer
regierungserklärung bleibt offen ob sie
dereinst in einem atemzug mit kohl
genannt werden oder mit kiesinger auf
denen die wirkliche erneuerung des
landes folgen musste
wir wünschen frau bundeskanzlerin wir
wünschen ihnen und ihrer regierung bei
ihren vorhaben im interesse des landes
erfolg und wir haben spannendes gehört
wir haben ein spannendes gehört
beispielsweise nannte horst seehofer
ihre politik 1 die herrschaft des
unrechts
nun ist er in ihr kabinett eingetreten
er hat als kabinettsmitglied angekündigt
dass er abschiebungen forcieren will und
dass er die kontrolle der grenzen
sicherstellen möchte herr seehofer ihr
niedersächsischer spd amtskollege boris
pistorius hat sie einen anschein
erwecken politiker genannt
ich kann ihnen versichern wenn sie das
recht durchsetzen wollen dann werden wir
sie vor jeder kritik der spd in schutz
nehmen dürfen sie sich auf uns verlassen
aber das ziel kann nicht die rückkehr
zuschlag bohren in europa sein sondern
das muss die kontrolle der europäischen
außengrenzen sein
diese regierung diese regierung herr
minister seehofer führt auf ihre
initiative allerdings auch eine debatte
darüber ob der islam zu deutschland
gehört wem nützt diese uneinigkeit
was soll aus dieser debatte tatsächlich
folgen aus welche antwort auch immer für
die million muslime die seit jahrzehnten
in unserem land leben
sie könnten sich eher minister seehofer
bleibende verdienste erwerben wenn die
csu sich endlich ihren eigenen dämonen
stellen würde
machen sie den weg frei für ein wirklich
weltoffenes einwanderungsgesetz und eine
integrationspolitik die religionen nicht
gegeneinander ausspielt sondern die
republikanischen werte des grundgesetzes
ins zentrum stellt
wir erlauben keinen rabatt wir erlauben
keinen rabatt die sind aber eben auch
nicht konfessionell gebunden der
gesundheitsminister jens spahn auch das
war spannend hat eine debatte eröffnet
um den sozialstaat treffsicherer zu
machen
dafür hat er widerspruch erhalten nicht
nur widerspruch von den grünen die die
gelegenheit genutzt haben um sich vom
prinzip des förderns und forderns der
agenda 2010 zu verabschieden und
dokumentiert haben dass sie in fragen
der sozialpolitik und das ist ja legitim
der linkspartei näher stehen als der spd
sondern sie haben auch widerspruch
erhalten aus ihren eigenen reihen der
union
was aber ist falsch an der debatte die
herr spahn eröffnet hat an der debatte
ist nicht falsch nichts falsch die frage
nach der konsequenz nur stellt sich denn
in der tat habe es vier sichert ein
existenzminimum sollte es das
existenzminimum nicht sichern müsste man
fragen was frau nahles die vergangenen
vier jahre gemacht hat aber dennoch kann
sich niemand mit hartz 4 zufrieden geben
und deshalb müsste müsste die regierung
dort sind impuls von dem sparen
aufnehmen den sozialstaat aktivierend
neu ausgestaltet und dafür sorgen dass
sich jede stunde zusätzliche arbeit für
einen hartz 4 empfänger auch wirklich
lohnt das wäre ein beitrag zur
leistungsgerechtigkeit
neue internetbeauftragte dorothee bär
hat uns flug taxis versprochen auch das
war spannend und das ist auch eine
wünschenswerte vision für alle
staugeplagten in deutschland an die
steuer wäre auf einen schlag alle sorgen
und probleme los aber wie wäre es mit
zunächst mit den basics beginnen also
schnell im internet oder papierloser
verwaltung und zwar nicht erst 2025
dazu ist eine bündelung von kompetenzen
nötig klare zuständigkeiten personelle
kapazitäten und das weiß die regierung
selbst dass bei wichtigen prioritären
vorhaben die kräfte gebündelt werden
müssen aber aus diesem wissen hat die
regierung kann digital ministerium
gemacht sondern das was horst seehofer
selbst ein heimatmuseum nennt manchmal
manchmal muss man nichts kritisieren
manchmal muss man nur zitieren wie
koalitionsvertrag gibt es indessen
zweimal positives zu würdigen und das
darf hier bei einer regierungserklärung
und der aussprache nicht unerwähnt
lassen
erstens gibt es eine bereitschaft zur
reform des bildungsföderalismus
das war am veto des grünen winfried
kretschmann in einer traumatisierenden
phase meines lebens im vergangenen jahr
gescheitert und frau nahles journalist
ich wünsche ihnen sagen die freien
demokraten werden die von der großen
koalition geplante änderung des
grundgesetzes natürlich unterstützen
aber
aber klar ist das ist nur ein erster
antrag haffter schritt in die richtige
richtung deutschland braucht viel mehr
mobilität mehr vergleichbarkeit mehr
qualität zwischen und in den 16
bildungssystem um tatsächlich
international anschluss zu finden
der digitaldruck der bundesregierung ist
indessen noch nicht in trockenen tüchern
das muss hier heute gesagt werden frau
bundeskanzlerin sie haben bei der
letzten konferenz mit den
ministerpräsidenten am ersten februar
eingeräumt dass die 3,5 milliarden euro
für den digital packt im
koalitionsvertrag noch nicht mit geld
hinterlegt sind
das muss man realisieren die mütter
rente kommt ganz sicher die bildung aber
steht unter finanzierungsvorbehalt
sie haben gesagt sie wollten im land
spaltungen verhindern und zusammenhalt
stärken
eine politik die die großmütter gegen
die enkel aus spielt die spaltet aber
das land
zweitens zweitens würdigen wir den neuen
klima realismus der koalition die ziele
des jahres 2020 sind physikalisch nicht
zu erreichen im vergangenen jahr war
dies umstritten
aber jetzt fehlt der notwendige nächste
schritt nämlich innovative und
realistische wege um wenigstens die
ziele des jahres 2030 zu erreichen
dazu ist eine wende nötig statt
planwirtschaft am reißbrett braucht
unser land einen marktwirtschaftlichen
weg also statt quoten verboten und
subventionen sollten wir den
innovationsmotor der sozialen
marktwirtschaft anwerfen welcher antrieb
der beste ist das muss wieder eine frage
von technikern werden und darf keine von
technokraten bleiben
über 200 stellen schafft die regierung
für sich selbst im regierungsapparat und
jenseits einmal jetzt des des
parteipolitischen boden turms
charakterisiert dass diese koalition der
spd reichen die mittel des vize-kanzlers
gabriel nicht aus es muss aufgestockt
werden horst seehofer baut mit dem
heimat ministerium ein zweites
vizekanzler amt und das ist ausdruck
offensichtlich eines misstrauens
innerhalb der regierung und es entlarvt
diese unterschiede überwunden haben
nicht durch richtungsentscheidungen
sondern durch geld peter altmaier hat
innerhalb von wenigen wochen milliarden
aus dem hut gezaubert
gegenüber dem jamaica verhandlungen hat
er innerhalb weniger wochen milliarden
zusätzliche euro gefunden man wünscht
sich ihn als privaten vermögensverwalter
niemals zuvor niemals zuvor hatte einer
regierung an solchen
verteilungsspielraum wie sie und dennoch
reicht er nicht um alle ihre
ausgabenwünsche zu finanzieren das
institut der deutschen wirtschaft in
köln beziffert das drohende defizit im
jahr 2021 auf 20 milliarden euro
wenn olaf scholz nicht aufpasst dann
wird er als der finanzminister in die
geschichte des landes eingehen der es
geschafft hat den staatshaushalt zu
boomzeiten zu ruinieren
wo sind die antworten auf die
herausforderung
wo sind die antworten auf die neuen
herausforderungen wir begrüßen die neue
flexibilität am arbeitsmarkt wir
begrüßen die konzentration auf
innovative technologien und bildung
wir begrüßen die spürbare entlastung der
breiten mitte des landes in frankreich
hierzulande geht es um mietpreis bremsen
um die einschränkung der
vertragsfreiheit am arbeitsmarkt es geht
um die erhöhung der abgeltungssteuer die
verlängerung des solidaritätszuschlags
und wie sie selbst eingeräumt haben die
absehbare steigerung des
rentenversicherungsbeitrags im nächsten
jahrzehnt also die bürokratie die makro
abbaut die wird in deutschland aufgebaut
die entlassung
die frankreich beschließt die bleiben in
deutschland aus 15 jahre nach der agenda
2010 kann man sagen
frankreich ist dabei deutschland zu
werden und deutschland ist dabei
französischer zu werden so haben wir uns
die deutsch-französische annäherung aber
nicht vorgestellt bundeskanzler europa
europa ist ein friedensprojekt sie haben
es zu recht betont angesichts der
herausforderungen durch china die türkei
durch russland und deshalb müssen die
fliehkräfte durch eine andere migrations
sicherheitspolitik bewältigt werden
die gefahr aber besteht lässt durch
falsche entscheidungen in der
währungspolitik neue fliehkräfte
entstehen deutschland hängt hier an den
lippen frankreichs der weg von wolfgang
schäuble wird absehbar verlassen sie
selbst haben davon gesprochen ist
benötigt wir zusätzliche finanzmittel
für wirtschaftliche konvergenz ist eine
diplomatische umschreibung für
transfer-union für finanzausgleich und
umverteilung
das ist wichtig zu sagen denn auch
unsere partner in dem niederland in
skandinavischen ländern und den ball zu
kommen sehen diese politik kritisch sie
erinnern an die finanzpolitische
eigenverantwortung man möge nur das
interview des niederländischen
ministerpräsidenten mark rutte dieser
tage lesen das spaltet europa wenn die
finanzpolitische eigenverantwortung in
frage gestellt wird und frau merkel weil
sie über die banken union gesprochen
haben wenn sie tatsächlich die
einlagensicherung beschließen und die
kunden von sparkassen und volksbanken in
deutschland in mithaftung geraten für
instabile institute anderswo in europa
dann stärkt das den europäischen
gedanken nicht sondern dann trat das ein
spaltpilz in das europäische einigung
ich begrüße dass frau nahles wie die
frau bundeskanzlerin über den freihandel
gesprochen haben also beschließen sie
doch dass zeta abkommen ratifizieren sie
es und fahren sie frau merkel kann sie
frau merkel doch nach washington zu
hören und sprechen sie doch über einen
neuen deal holen sieht tipp aus dem
eisschrank heraus und sorgen sie dafür
dass ist ein freien handel gibt man kann
mit trump sprechen
man kann mit trump sprechen man kann mit
herrn trump deals erzielen was die
nordkoreaner geschafft haben das
schaffen sie schon lange vor
bundeskanzlerin und sie kommen zur
letzten abschließende gedanken
diese koalition hat von sich gesagt sie
sei eine koalition der kleinen leute
herr seehofer nicht ich kenne in diesem
land bürgerinnen und bürger mit geringem
einkommen
ich kenne bürgerinnen und bürger ich
kenne bürgerinnen und bürger sollten sie
immer
warten sie mal ab ihre reaktion spricht
bereits bände
ich kenne bürgerinnen und bürger die
sind bedürftig sie sind auf hilfe und
solidarität angewiesen aber wissen sie
was unserem land nicht blieb es gibt
keine kleinen leute auf die eine
regierung von oben herab schauen kann
es sind die bürgerinnen und bürger es
ist hier souverän und der verdient
respekt
lindner war das der fraktions und
parteivorsitzende der fdp der zugibt
dass jamaika verhandlung im vergangenen
jahr eine traumatisierende phase in
seinem leben war ein anderes trauma muss
ja wohl berichten angela merkel
verarbeiten
er begann seine rede mit der
feststellung dass helmut kohl ein großer
kanzler war
und frau merkel habe so oft gesagt seien
wir doch mal ehrlich das dass die frage
aufwirft was in den vergangenen zwölf
jahren war damit suggeriert also im
grunde genommen dass angela merkel nicht
so redner jetzt volker kauder und das
wird auch nicht nur in diesem haus
sondern von den menschen erwartet gibt
antworten auf die großen
herausforderungen die vor uns stehen und
die großen herausforderungen mit sich an
einigen beispielen nennen
da ist die erste große herausforderung
europa und deshalb steht das thema
europa auch ganz vorn im
koalitionsvertrag und europa wird
darüber entscheiden ob wir eine gute
zukunft haben oder nicht da sind wir uns
ja einig denn
europa ist für uns notwendig um deutsche
interessen erfolgreich in der welt zu
vertreten
alleine werden wird es nicht schaffen
und deshalb kommt es jetzt darauf an
dieses europa wieder dynamisch zu
gestalten
da hat makro vorlagen gemacht und wir
geben darauf antworten und eine antwort
heißt ja wir wollen dass auch in europa
die wachstumsimpulse gestärkt werden
es hat sich in europa einiges verändert
in ländern die große probleme hatten
sehen wir eine gute entwicklung das muss
weiter unterstützt werden und dieses
europa muss natürlich auch unsere
handels interessen vertreten
wir werden in der diskussion mit den
vereinigten staaten für unsere
interessen keinen erfolg haben wenn
dieses europa nicht zusammen steht ist
darf auf keinen fall passieren dass ein
europäisches land versucht andere
lösungen mit amerika zu finden als wir
miteinander und deshalb ist dieses
europa für uns eine zentrale sache einen
hinweis möchte ich natürlich schon geben
nicht um einen blick zurück zu werfen
sondern um uns zu bestärken richtige
dinge in der zukunft zu machen
wir hätten manches problem jetzt nicht
wenn wir bereit gewesen wären
freihandelsabkommen mit den vereinigten
staaten viel konsequenter zu verfolgen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das muss
uns auch klar werden an gerade an dem
beispiel was jetzt in mit amerika
geschieht sieht man wie
freihandelsabkommen einem auch schützen
können und deswegen bin ich schon der
meinung dass sollten auf jeden fall des
zeta jetzt mal auf den weg bringen und
andere gelegenheiten freihandelsabkommen
zu schließen nicht außer acht zu lassen
wir haben antworten gegeben für den
reformkurs in europa aber eines will ich
auch deutlich sagen ja wir können uns
vorstellen dass aus dem esm
beispielsweise ein europäischer
währungsfonds entstehen kann wie es
makro formuliert hat aber nur dann wenn
dies einen zusätzlichen mehrwert
bedeutet nur für eine umfirmierung
stehen wir nicht zur verfügung und
zweitens darauf legen wir in den
unionsfraktionen großen wert wir werden
nur dann einer entwicklung zustimmen
wenn die parlamentarischen rechte in
keinster weise eingeschränkt werden
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir haben beteiligungsrechte formuliert
so stark wie in keinem anderen
europäischen nationalen parlament und
auf die werden wir auch setzen und die
müssen beibehalten werden bei den
entwicklungen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wenn wir eine zweite große
herausforderung uns anschauen heißt die
wir müssen unsere wirtschaftliche
wettbewerbsfähigkeit erhalten
bevor wir über soziale fragen sprechen
komme ich auch noch drauf muss aber klar
sein wir werden kein einziges soziales
problem wirklich lösen können wenn wir
die wirtschaftliche wettbewerbsfähigkeit
in unserem land
erhalten zunächst muss erwirtschaftet
werden
dann können wir auch an andere dinge
denken
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir
signale in die wirtschaft aus senden
die bundeskanzlerin hat es angesprochen
wir wollen die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
deutschen wirtschaft durch
forschungsförderung stärken
über viele viele jahre hinweg haben auch
wir immer wieder gefordert es muss eine
steuerliche forschungsförderung geben in
dieser legislaturperiode wird sie kommen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen und zwar
meine ich sie muss relativ rasch kommen
es muss eine der ersten maßnahmen sein
die wir jetzt seien in den nächsten
monaten auf beschließen und meine damen
und herren die wirtschaft fördern heißt
auch wahrscheinlich die größte
gesellschaftliche herausforderung
nämlich die digitalisierung auf den weg
zu bringen
wir müssen mit der wirtschaft darüber
sprechen was jetzt getan werden muss
aber das wichtigste ist dass wir die
infrastruktur schnell ausbauen denn die
ist die voraussetzung für die
digitalisierung und jetzt sage ich etwas
was unser land über viele jahre hinweg
leider gottes auf ausgezeichnet hat mit
einer ganz großen ausnahme in unserem
land geht vieles viel zu langsam voran
liebe kolleginnen kollegen von der
entscheidung eine autobahn zu bauen bis
zum ersten spatenstich vorgehen im
schnitt 13 jahre das ist für eine
moderne investitionspolitik entschieden
zu viel und das haben wir damals als die
deutsche einheit kam geändert und da
finde ich daran müssen wir wieder
anknüpfen und deswegen
finde ich es wirklich gut dass es
gelungen ist im koalitionsvertrag ein
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz zu
beschließen und dass wir zusätzlich
beschlossen haben dass wir ein paar
wenige große maßnahmen auch in einem
maßnahmen gesetz voranbringen wollen
und beide punkte
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz und
maßnahmen gesetz müssen bis zum ende des
jahres auf den weg gebracht sein damit
wir die projekte die wir haben auch
umsetzen können und zweitens wenn man
davon spricht wirtschaft fördern ein
großes thema ist der fachkräftemangel
da kann man natürlich mit einem
einwanderungs fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz versuchen das ein
oder andere zu erreichen
ich kann nur sagen den großen den
größten teil der fachkräfte die wir in
der wirtschaft brauchen werden wir für
unser land nicht aus dem ausland
bekommen
die müssen wir in unserem eigenen land
ausbilden und deshalb ist eine
bildungspolitik die einen schwerpunkt
darauf setzt von größter bedeutung wir
haben gesehen was in ländern passiert
wenn man eine einseitige akademisierung
vorantreibt spanien ist dafür ein
beispiel
und deswegen finde ich es richtig dass
wir gesagt haben wir werden in dieser
regierungskoalition einen schwerpunkt
auf die duale und sprich auf die
berufliche bildung legen das ist dir
wirklich gute weg fachkräfte für unser
land zu gewinnen
und da hoffe ich auch dass wir mit den
ländern hier entsprechende
vereinbarungen erzielen
und wenn wir über die digitalisierung
sprechen ist auch klar das wird für die
menschen veränderungen bedeuten da habe
ich wenig gehört aus anderen bereichen
dieses hauses immer damit umgeht und
deswegen ist es völlig richtig dass wir
gesagt haben und da helfen wir der
wirtschaft auch dass wir bei der
digitalisierung alles daran setzen
werden dass niemand zurück bleibt und
dies heißt dass ihr fort und
weiterbildung in großem umfang
vorantreiben müssen und daran werden wir
uns auch finanziell beteiligen müssen
sonst wird es vor allem der kleineren
mittelstand nicht schaffen die
kolleginnen kollegen und meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ja richtig
ist auch dass eine entwicklung in
unserem land auch davon abhängt dass wir
sicherheit garantieren können wir von
der union reden immer auch davon dass
freiheit ein zentrales thema unserer
politik ist freiheit sich selbst zu
entscheiden die man sein leben führen
will aber zur freiheit gehört sicherheit
und deswegen bin ich sehr zufrieden
damit was wir im koalitionsvertrag zum
thema sicherheit miteinander vereinbart
haben und es gilt es jetzt auch ganz
rasch und schnell umzusetzen
jetzt kann man natürlich sagen bestimmte
themen herr lindner brauchen wir gar
nicht ansprechen aber ich sage mal es
bedeutet für uns eine herausforderung
dass es bereiche kleinere bereiche in
unserem land in großen städten gibt wo
eben die durchsetzung des rechtsstaats
und des gesetzes nicht so ist wie wir
uns das vorstellen
das recht muss durchgesetzt werden damit
sicherheit
sondern tatsächlich entstehen kann liebe
kollegin kollegen und dafür braucht man
personal einmal bei der polizei aber
auch bei der justiz was alles
beschlossen ist was wir jetzt schnell
auf den weg bringen werden
und natürlich ist es auch richtig was
die bundeskanzlerin gesagt hat dass wir
natürlich den menschen die aus
bürgerkriegs regionen kommen und die
einen asylrecht haben hier eine
aufenthalt genehmigen aber genauso
richtig ist es und es ist auch
rechtsstaat nichts anderes dass
diejenigen die kein aufenthaltsrecht
haben unser land schnellstmöglich wieder
verlassen müssen liebe kolleginnen
kollegen und da wir gesehen haben dass
dies umso schwerer wird hier schneller
die menschen in gemeinden kommen und
dort dann freundschaften nachbarschaften
oder indem sie auch verschwinden ist es
richtig dass wir sagen die verfahren
werden in sogenannten anker
einrichtungen schleunigst vorangetrieben
und dann gehen die menschen wenn sie
kein recht haben nach hause und da kann
ich ihnen nur sagen das ist im tiefsten
sinne human
ich habe mich nämlich mal erkundigt was
den flüchtlingen passiert auf dem weg
von der sub sahara bis sie endlich in
nordafrika angekommen sind
unmenschliche aktionen von
schleuserbanden und von denen von banden
die in libyen sich mit diesen menschen
in lagern sie quälen und beschäftigen da
kann ich nur sagen das beste ist wenn
die menschen erst gar nicht auf die
flucht geschickt werden sondern wenn sie
zukunftsperspektiven in ihrer heimat
haben und dafür werden wir uns einsetzen
und licht noch schlepperbanden
motivieren
diese arbeit in zukunft weiter zu führen
und einen letzten punkt wir alle sind
davon überzeugt dass wir den
außenpolitischen herausforderungen nicht
einfach zuschauen können
ich finde dass der nato-rat sich mit dem
was die türkei im augenblick unternimmt
beschäftigen muss die nato ist nicht nur
ein verteidigungsbündnis sondern auch
die nato ist ein wärter bündnis liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und es kann
doch unmöglich sein das wir zuschauen
wie ein nato-mitglied menschenrechte
verletzt und genau das geschieht im
augenblick weiter türkei und es darf
nicht unwidersprochen bleiben
jetzt weiß ich sehr wohl dass dieser
satz einfach zu sagen ist und wir auf
der anderen seite aber auch wissen
welche gefahren lauern
einer der sich riesig darüber freuen
würde wenn die türkei die nato fall ist
das wäre putin und genau das wollen wir
auch nicht und darin liegt eine gewisse
problematik den laden zusammenzuhalten
und trotzdem das nicht einfach
hinzunehmen was im augenblick im norden
syriens geschieht und deswegen werden
wir uns mehr auch mit diesen themen
beschäftigen müssen und ich finde eine
entsprechende außenpolitische debatte
zudem fragen würde uns gut anstehen und
es hat auch natürlich ein gewisses
problem wenn wir sagen ein thema von mir
wir müssen uns natürlich auch für
verfolgte christen wir sagen g7 und
andere einsetzen
aber was dort in afrika gerade passiert
das hat mit dem schutz von verfolgten
herzlich wenig zu tun liebe kolleginnen
kollegen und deswegen müssen wir uns
schon die frage stellen was kann unser
beitrag dazu sein
also wenn ich mir dies alles anschauen
dann muss ich sagen es hat lange
gedauert
wir haben jetzt ein halbes jahr
gebraucht bis nur eine regierung haben
bilden können
und jetzt muss einiges wieder
hereingeholt werden in der zeit schnell
ein paar dinge auf den weg gebracht
werden
aber wenn ich mir anschaue was wir als
koalitionsvertrag vorlegen vorgelegt
haben dann bin ich ganz sicher
darin stecken alle möglichkeiten wenn
wir es richtig machen das land
dynamischer zu machen einen neuen
aufbruch in europa hin zu bekommen und
den zusammenhalt in unserem land zu
stärken
soweit der fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu
csu fraktion volker kauder der hier am
meisten applaus für seine bemerkung dass
man dem türkischen partner haften so
nicht durchgehen lassen kam nächster
redner dietmar bartsch mir dass der
fraktionsvorsitzende der linkspartei
haben wir seit sieben tagen eine
regierung in deutschland und die hat
sich in diesen sieben tagen wirklich von
ihrer charmantesten seite gezeigt
vermerken sie haben hier in ihrer
erklärung davon gesprochen dass spaltung
überwunden werden sollen
aber ich kann nur sagen das was in der
ersten woche hier stattgefunden hat das
war doch das blanke chaos wegen der
bayerischen landtagswahl spielt er aus
bayern abgeschobene neue innenminister
hier den harten hund und macht einen auf
verbalradikalismus soll dass die art und
weise der arbeitsteilung in den nächsten
vier jahren sein
ich hätte mir da sehr übrigen gilt das
grundgesetz auch für innenminister
vielleicht hat ihn das noch keiner
gesagt und sie sind so lange weg ich
will es noch mal sagen ich hätte mir ich
hätte mir von ihnen gewünscht dass sie
klar sagen was nicht zu deutschland
gehört rassismus ausgrenzung und
menschen hast gar nicht zu deutschland
das ist die wahrheit meine damen und
herren
und ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass
alle neuen ministerinnen und minister
klar sagen dass wir armut in unserem
reichen land nicht akzeptieren werden
denn armut ist immer auch politisches
versagen dass menschen zu tafeln gehen
müssen ist politisches versagen meine
damen und herren
und niemand aus dem bundestag sollte
sich arrogant über die menschen erheben
die etwas leisten wo regierungspolitik
versagt hat meine damen und herren
eines können wir festhalten
wenn das so weitergeht wo merkel dann
werden die letzten vier jahre ihrer
liege ihre amtszeit wirklich chaotische
jahre werden denn der anfang
der war wirklich eine katastrophe es war
auch nicht so sehr viel anderes zu
erwarten denn es treffen sich hier die
wahlverlierer die union hat 8,6 prozent
verloren
die spd hat 5,2 prozent verloren ja das
ist eine reine not koalition die sich
hier zusammen und ich will heribert
prantl zitieren aus der süddeutschen
zeitung
der hat so schön beträgt geschrieben
autorität schafft man nicht dadurch dass
man das wort weiter so einfach durch
erneuerung ersetzt da hat der mann
völlig recht meine damen und herren in
den koalitionsvertrag steht viel lyrik
aber gegen alle beteuerungen von heute
es ist ohne aufbruch es ist ohne schwung
wo sie jetzt der schwungvoller sehr
schwungvoll
das war beim personal und bei der
einstellungspolitik die erste maßnahme
35 staatssekretäre und staatsminister so
viele wie noch nie in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik
und jeder staatssekretär oder
staatsminister kostet circa eine halbe
million euro meine damen und herren das
ist doch nicht normal ich meine bei der
spd frage ich mich da ist er jetzt jeder
staatsminister ausschussvorsitzender
fraktion stellvertreter fraktionsloser
jeder hatten post nie krieg mit ausnahme
von sigmar gabriel und martin schulz
japan haben eingekriegt meine damen und
die nächste maßnahme die nächste mal
russland das sich erst mal überall
ordentliche machtzentren geschaffen
werden da werden bei herrn seehofer 1200
neue stellen im innenministerium
geschaffen habe ich frau merkel im
kanzleramt 40 neue stellen geschaffen
da werden dahin scholz 40 neue stellen
im finanzministerium geschaffen
diese selbstbedienungsmentalität steht
in keiner relation zu ihren wahlergebnis
meine damen und herren der
koalitionsvertrag den sie ja hier
referiert hat ist in der substanz ein
dokument des weiter so machen sich das
anguckt und auch die heutige
regierungserklärung gehört hat dann kann
man natürlich da auch unterstützenswerte
vorhaben finden das ja unbestritten
immer zwei rausgesucht die ich zumindest
was die überschriften beträgt
ausgesprochen ausgesprochen
begrüßenswert halte kinderarmut endlich
entschlossen bekämpfen
und auch das thema europa abkehr von der
sparpolitik zur kinder haben als erste
mal das erste mal steht kinderarmut in
dieser form im koalitionsvertrag und
dass man dort etwas tun will das hat
mich auch persönlich sehr gefreut wir
haben seit zwei jahren als linke ein
netzwerk gegen kinderarmut es hat
offensichtlich ein bisschen wirkung
gezeigt ich freue mich auch dass
kinderrechte ins grundgesetz kommen
sollen rechtsanspruch auf
ganztagsbetreuung insgesamt sind ist ja
zwölf millionen die ausgegeben werden
sollen das in ordnung
ich will aber schon mal darauf verweisen
dass für 2,7 millionen kinder haben die
arm sind oder von armut bedroht sind ist
natürlich ein riesen problem und da
frage ich mich natürlich auch wer hat
denn in den letzten jahren die
regierungsverantwortung getragen
irgendwer ist doch dafür zuständig dass
wir dahin gekommen sind und jetzt und
ich will das ergänzen einzig noch
ergänzen
seit der einführung von hartz iv hat
sich kinderarmut in deutschland
verdoppelt so viel nur dazu dass hartz 4
vor armut schützen soll
lieber herr sparen lieber herr lindner
das nämlich nicht der fall seit dieser
gesetze ist die armut ist die
kinderarmut verdoppelt und jetzt haben
sie also unter
anderen beschlossen 25 euro mehr
kindergeld als zunächst mal ist ja schon
interessant 15 davon gibt es im jahr
2021 in dem wahljahr und nicht etwa
jetzt gleich aber das war es wirklich
sehr durchsichtig aber was ich schon
betonen will
wir abgeordnete profitieren von der
kindergelderhöhung aber die
alleinerziehende mutter die hartz4
bekommt da wird das kindergeld die
erhöhung angerechnet meine damen und
herren das ist eine schreiende
ungerechtigkeit da fehlen mir beinahe
die worte
das kann doch nicht ihr ernst sein da
müssen wir doch was machen das spüren
die leute doch dass dadurch die soziale
spaltung in unserem land eher verschärft
wird ändern sie das ändern sie das wir
brauchen bei dem thema kinderarmut einem
systemwechsel eine kindergrundsicherung
wäre notwendig die wirklich etwas
fundamental bewegen kann jedes kind muss
die chance auf ein gutes leben haben und
jedes kind muss uns gleich viel wert
sein meine damen und herren ich will zu
europa etwas sagen kurz vermerken sie
haben ja sehr viel dazu gesagt der
koalitionsvertrag spielt es eine noch
größere rolle
aber ich will da schon mal festhalten
dass es einen punkt gibt wo man die
unaufrichtigkeit wirklich deutlich sehen
kann
wir nehmen mal sie reden von ende der
sparpolitik oder scholz ist aber ein
verfechter der schwarzen null überall in
europa und es ist ja im kern egal ob die
schwarzen ob 0 schwarz oder rot ist 0
ist nun mal ne 0
aber der fetisch des ausgeglichenen
haushaltes der hat halb europa in den
abgrund getrieben meine damen und herren
aber sie bleiben da nicht bei der 0 und
jetzt kommt das symbol was sich hier
nennen will
sie holen sich ein staatssekretär herrn
jörg cookies ins ministerium der von
goldman sachs kommt also die älteren
hier im bundestag erinnern sich ja noch
das ist die truppe die bei bilanzbetrug
riechen
lanz federführend war damit griechenland
in den euro kommt die haben daran
verdient dass es die truppe direkt an
der griechenland-krise pro er verdient
hat goldman sachs hat auf die
finanzkrise gerettet meine damen und
herren was ist das denn für ein symbol
ich sag das selten aber schämen sie sich
nicht bis geführt man muss eher angst
kriegen wenn die europa höhere
aufmerksamkeit widmen wollen auch da ist
das ergebnis ihrer politik der bremse
die ergebnisse im detail das hat doch
alles auch etwas mit deutscher politik
zu tun was gänzlich fehlt im
koalitionsvertrag ist das thema
umverteilt und ich glaube das ist ein
zentrales thema offensichtlich kennen
sie das wort ich bei ihnen steht drin
das ist dass sie keine steuererhöhungen
plan für niemanden
also auch nicht für die superreichen in
diesem land aber die soziale spaltung
die lässt sich nicht einfach hinweg
wünschen meine damen und herren die
steuerungerechtigkeit muss beendet
werden
wir haben ein steuersystem aus dem
vergangenen jahrhundert und es gibt
vielfältigen und sehr dringenden
reformbedarf auf dieser strecke
es kann doch nicht sein dass wir zusehen
dass die zahl der milliardäre in
deutschland groß größer wird dass die
zahl der vermögensmillionäre steigt bei
uns in deutschland ist es besonders
ungerecht die 45 reichsten haushalte in
deutschland besitzen soviel wie die
hälfte der bevölkerung da ist sowas
nicht normal meine damen und herren
da muss man doch handle aber sie trauen
sich nicht sie trauen sich nicht sich
mit den konzernen und mit den
superreichen anzulegen vermögenssteuer
fehlanzeige erbschaftsteuerreform
fehlanzeige abbau des mittelstandsbauchs
fehlanzeige abbau der kalten progression
fehlanzeige finanztransaktionssteuer
noch butterweicher als im letzten
koalitionsvertrag also das alles ist
doch meines erachtens ganz ganz schlimm
und sie haben jetzt hier von der
quadratur des kreises gesprochen die ist
ja unmöglich aber da will ich auf das
beispiel mit ihnen diesen denn schon
noch mal kommen also ein thema diesen
und fahrverbote lässt sich doch die
politik wunderbar erkennen dass sich nur
eine ganz gewichtige ökologische frage
sollte ist natürlich auch eine zentrale
soziale frage dass sie sich nicht trauen
die autokonzerne die verantwortung zu
nehmen da dürfen wir jetzt die
dieselfahrer besitzer mit fahrverboten
ausbauen
das treibt die leute im alltag rum und
da gucken sie de facto weg vw verkündet
riesen rekordgewinne und dann das dass
die leute da wütend werden dass doch
logisch meine damen und herren bei hat
jetzt tausend mal gesagt wir müssen in
die zukunft investieren
donnerwetter völlig richtig da haben sie
recht aber darüber reden sie auch seit
jahren wir sind immer noch unterhalb des
europäischen durchschnitts und wächter
so eine zahl sehe 5 milliarden in fünf
jahren in die schulen nach donnerwetter
welche das auf teile dann kommt nicht
mal in jeder schule eine maurerkelle an
das ist viel zu wenig sie müssen endlich
klotzen und nicht kleckern plätze
erklärt in dieser situation und das
trifft für die digitale infrastruktur zu
das trifft für den klimaschutz zu
das trifft für die pflege zu das ist
natürlich auch was sie nach vorschlagen
da loben sie sich noch für das alles
viel zu wenig das weiß hier jeder im
haus die mine zu versteigen sich in flug
taxi träume aber in den schulen dagegen
weiter durch das kann keine vernünftige
politik seien eine nachhaltige
investitions offensive öffentliche und
private investitionen wären notwendig
und dann gründen sie noch kommissionen
ohne ende der alte satz wenn ich nicht
mehr weiter weiß gründe ich einen
arbeitskreis der bekommt hier wirklich
völlig neue dimensionen rente pflege
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse ost
west und und und ihnen fehlt es am
politischen willen etwas zu verändern
das ist der punkt und dann lassen sie
mich eine bemerkung zum osten machen
wir haben ja bekanntlich wirklich sehr
am herzen liegt und sie haben ja heute
leider frau bundeskanzlerin gar nichts
zugesagt im koalitionsvertrag kommt der
osten in der präambel vor und sonst nur
als nahen osten und als kosten ich finde
das ist ein problem meine damen und
herren ich finde es ein problem
wir brauchen uns nicht zu wundern wenn
der frust besonders weg auch hier ist
das problem nicht mit einer kommission
zu lösen sondern es muss gehandelt
werden
lassen sie mich noch ein paar wenige
bemerkung zur außenpolitik machen weil
das war ja erstaunlich mit welcher
selbstkritischen komponente sie hier
agiert haben manches teile ich da sehr
dass die uhren hilfsprogramme gekürzt
worden sind ist ein unding
da hätten wir auch ganz engagierte
vorgehen müssen aber zur außenpolitik
dieses symbol dass wir in dieser woche
sechs auslands mandate der bundeswehr
verlängert als allererstes das sagt doch
ganz ganz viel und die werden einfach
durchgewunken
da gibt es gar keine diskussion mehr
frau merkel ihnen nimmt doch ihre partei
im kern übel dass sie zu einem gewissen
zeitpunkt menschlichkeit gezeigt haben
und ich frage mich wer trägt eine
mitverantwortung des menschen flüchten
richtig auch die bundesregierung trägt
mitverantwortung mit waffenexporten mit
kriegseinsätzen mit obszönen
handelsüberschüssen und mit einer
bündnispolitik die zum haareraufen ist
ich meine die türkei ich bin ja dankbar
herr kauder ist überhaupt erwähnt haben
die führen einen völkerrechtswidrigen
krieg und haben 18 jetzt platt gemacht
aber mit deutschen waffen durch afrika
fährt ein leopard panzer dieses symbol
ist doch furchtbar führen sind ein
versagen der politik auf diesem sektor
ein werk bündnis haben sie gesagt jawoll
stoppen sie alle rüstungsexporte dahin
in den letzten wochen gegen andere
betreuung sind 20 exportgenehmigungen
höhe von 4,4 millionen genehmigt worden
in den letzten wochen tun sie was als
fraktionsvorsitzender lassen das nicht
zu dass ihre regierung so ein
beim herrn fakt bleibt von dieser
kleinen schwarz roten koalition kann man
festhalten es ist keine große weder
numerisch noch vom politischen anspruch
es gibt keine große reformvorhaben keine
grundsätzlichen änderungen sind geplant
viele kommissionen flickwerk und
projizierter permanenter interner zoff
wir können uns auf turbulente jahre
einrichten weil es weder eine
liebesheirat noch mit zweck hochzeit ist
es ist einfach zum scheitern verurteilt
und gegen ihre ankündigung seien sie mal
nicht so sicher was nach der nächsten
wahl ist überhaupt noch für diese
koalition reicht herzlichen dank herr
kollege dr am turmhof reiter spricht 45
bis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
frau bundeskanzlerin ja sie haben recht
wir haben eine lange regierungsbildung
erlebt leider ist es so was lange währt
wird nicht automatisch gut aber ich
glaube dass trotzdem viele menschen hier
in deutschland und im ausland froh sind
dass die unklarheit vorbei ist aber es
kommt jetzt darauf an was wir was die
demokratischen abgeordneten die
demokratischen fraktionen alle gemeinsam
in opposition und den
regierungsfraktionen daraus machen denn
denn wir als demokratische abgeordnete
haben ein gemeinsames interesse und das
ist gemeinsame interesse ist dass wir
die identifikation aller menschen in
diesem land mit rechtsstaat mit
demokratie massiv stärken und das ist
das interesse der demokratischen
fraktionen hier im deutschen bundestag
und wir grüne werden uns mit der
regierung ganz hart auseinandersetzen
denn wir sind in vielen punkten
grundsätzlich anderer meinung
wir sind grundsätzlich anderer meinung
bei der klimapolitik wir haben eine
grundsätzlich andere position zu der
flüchtlingspolitik wie sie inzwischen
machen und wir haben auch in vielen
punkten eine grundsätzlich andere
haltung zur sozialpolitik aber ich
glaube dass es uns allen gut tut das
wenn wir bei aller heftigen leidenschaft
die dazugehört
trotzdem respekt füreinander haben und
dass wir bei aller eigenen überzeugung
trotzdem auf die argumente der anderen
hören und eingehen sollten
und ich glaube es würde dieser großen
koalition verdammt gut tun wenn sie auch
das eine oder andere argument auch aus
der opposition eingeht und nicht wieder
eine schwarz-rote trutzburg bildet und
in der kürze der zeit kann ich nur ein
paar wenige punkte eingehen
vorne weg zu etwas was vorher gesagt
worden es nur ganz kurz helgoland ich
weiß in welchem jahrhundert zu leben
aber einen fundamentalen unterschied zur
zeit von bismarck nur genannt
frankreich ist jetzt unsere engster
verbündeter und wir führen keinen krieg
mit frankreich ich glaube dass ein
relevanter unterschied aventis fleisch
direkt ankommt
und nur eine anmerkung zur herr lindner
es tut mir leid dass sie die zeit damals
traumatisiert hat aber es tut mir noch
leiter dass man ihre rede anmerkt hat
dass sie ihr trauma leider noch nicht
den runden haben
um jetzt und jetzt vielleicht zur
regierungserklärung von frau merkel
wissen sie in der regierungserklärung
von infra merkel habe ich ja sehr
geschätzt zu hören dass sie etwas tun
wollen um den zusammenhalt in diesem
land sowohl sozial als auch
gesellschaftlich zu stärken
da schaue ich mir bloß die vergangene
woche ihres eigenen kabinetts an und ich
dachte mir so spontan also ihre rede
hören
morgen wird herr seehofer entlassen und
übermorgen ist herr spahn fällig das
wäre doch die konsequenz aus ihrer
regierungserklärung nicht was hat denn
herr seehofer gemacht als neuer
innenminister noch nicht spannend welche
verantwortung er trägt er hat dazu
beigetragen die gesellschaft in diesem
land tiefer zu spalten und deshalb hat
der vorsitzende herr vorsitzender
verband deutscher kriminalbeamter recht
wer solche aussagen tätig ist ein
sicherheitsrisiko herrn seehofer
herr seehofer ihnen ist es gelungen
sowohl dem ganz rechten rand als auch
den islamisten an gefallen zu tun mit
ihren aussagen und das ist wirklich
nicht hilfreich
wissen sie was ich von einem
innenminister erwarten würde der
verantwortungsvoll ist von dem
innenminister würde ich erwarten dass es
sich um die realen probleme gibt dies
gekümmert ich es gibt nehmen wir zum
beispiel die vernünftige zusammenarbeit
unserer sicherheitsbehörden
wir haben ihren gemeinsamen
untersuchungsausschuss eingesetzt warum
haben wir den eingesetzt weil der
anschlag auf dem breitscheidplatz auch
wohl einfach sagen unserer
sicherheitsbehörden war
kümmern sie sich darum dann hätten sie
auch unsere unterstützung
und was sie halt auch überhaupt
gebrauchen essen gesundheitsminister der
glaubt seine karriere seine konservative
eher konservativ ist es ja gar nicht
also das ist eine schande für die
konservativen also seine karriere im
rechten flügel der union auf dem rücken
der schwächsten aufbauen zu können
müssen sie wissen sie ersparen sie
wissen doch auch das seit zehn jahren
seit zehn jahren die sätze für das
arbeitslosengeld 2 künstlich herunter
gerechnet
ersparen sie wissen doch auch dass man
mit zwei euro 77 pro tag ein kind nicht
vernünftig ernähren kann
also lassen sie sich das doch um kümmert
sie sich um ihre eigenen aufgaben
da wär's zum beispiel sich zu überlegen
wie man wirklich bei der pflege was
macht und frau merkel gesagt die 8000
zusätzlichen stellen sind erster schritt
er verdammt noch mal wir waren doch
schon mal weiter da gab es 25.000
zusätzliche stellen kümmert sie sich
darum
dann hätten sie unsere unterstützung und
was ich ehrlich sagt witter finden an
der ganzen geschichte ist das von der
spd wenn die schwächsten bei uns im land
so diffamiert werden weil eigentlich
nichts dazu gehört
und wissen sie canales herr heil ich
finds ja gut wenn sie sich darum kümmern
wollen dass mehr menschen in arbeit
kommen wenn auch mehr
langzeitarbeitslose in arbeit kommen und
das mit sozialen arbeitsmarkt ist eine
gute geschichte aber aber er steht hat
bei uns im grundgesetz nicht die würde
des arbeitenden menschen ist unantastbar
sah da steht drin die würde des menschen
ist unantastbar und deshalb hätte ich
erwartet dass sie im ärmsten der armen
gegen ihren koalitionspartner
verteidigen lassen sie uns gemeinsam für
ein sozialsystem sagen dass die würde
aller menschen ins zentrum stellt das
wäre die aufgabe
steht noch ganz kurz noch ganz kurz zur
klimapolitik
das problematische war der klimapolitik
sowie sie machen ist dass sie da massiv
vertrauen massiv vertrauen in unserer
gesellschaft zerstören nämlich
klimapolitik erfolgreiche umweltpolitik
ist langfristige umbau geschichte das
ist etwas wo unternehmen investieren
müssen wo sich menschen langfristig
darauf einstellen können müssen und
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass die
verlässlichkeit das vertrauen in die
verlässlichkeit der politik da ist und
mit dem abräumen des klimaschutzziels
2020 haben sie genau diese
verlässlichkeit zerstört mit dem
durchgehend der tricksereien der
autokonzerne haben sie genau diese
verlässlichkeit zerstört denn wie soll
ein unternehmer der millionen
investieren will in klimaschutz denn das
gegenüber seinen investoren begründen
wenn sein konkurrent sich darauf
verlassen können dass die
klimaschutzziele immer und immer wieder
verschoben werden
wie soll denn ein manager da gibt es
auch progressive in autoindustrie
durchsetzen dass man endlich moderne
saubere antrieb produziert wenn sie
zulassen dass die tricks herein immer
und immer und immer wieder weitergeht
ändern sie das endlich nämlich dadurch
wird ihre dadurch wird ihre klimapolitik
auch noch eine richtig schlechte eine
richtig schlechte wirtschaftspolitik und
zum abschluss noch 1 man könnte noch zu
ganz vielen dingen was sagen zu europa
müssen wir dringend was sagen dass sie
endlich aufhören die vorschläge von
makro immer als transferunion zu
diffamieren man müsste auch dringend was
dazu sagen kann dass das was sie gesagt
haben zur nato afrika und der türkei ja
verdammt nochmal sie haben da ja recht
aber was macht denn diese
bundesregierung da muss halt diese
bundesregierung endlich mal den nato
beraten andere
anstatt in einer tour weiter waffen
dahin zu liefern
sie sagen hier das richtige uns
gegenteil jetzt von ihrer
bundesregierung macht und er erwarte ich
von ihnen als regierungsfraktionen dass
sie sich durchsetzen und deshalb zum
abschluss zum abschluss nur eins die
ersten wochen habe man erkennen können
dass die koalitions fraktionen und
parteien vor allem mit sich selbst
beschäftigt sind ersparen gegen annegret
kramp karrenbauer von alesund die spd
sowieso mit sich selbst beschäftigt ob
bei der csu gibt es einen wettbewerb
zwischen seehofer und söder wir am
weitesten nach rechts aus schlecht hören
sie damit auf denn wir brauchen dringend
eine regierung die die großen probleme
dieses landes anpackt tun sie das
wünsche ich mir bereits opposition ist
wünsche ich mir vor allem als bürger
dieses landes vielen dank anton
hofreiter mit einer kämpferischen rede
der fraktionsvorsitzende grünen war der
letzte redner jetzt in der ersten
erwiderung runde sechs fraktionen im
parlament da dauert das etwas länger als
das früher der fall war und